at seven o'clock this is a Sky News
special on the crisis in the channel
tonight we ask can the small boats be
stopped
the Prime Minister has laid out plans to
stop people crossing the channel from
France
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
but there are doubts over the legality
of the plan with labor describing it as
unworkable
they could be setting out a serious plan
today and we would work with them on it
and so would everyone across the country
instead it's just more chaos
where she sooner consists the
legislation is compliant with
international law we'll dive into the
detail with an immigration lawyer
and we'll ask is enough being done to
stop those sending the boats the people
Smugglers
foreign
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the special
Sky News program asking can the small
boats be stopped well the Prime Minister
has published plans to stop people
making the journey across the English
Channel but there are questions over the
legality of those plans with a Home
Secretary herself admitting it pushes
the boundaries of international law
so what's in the legislation let's take
a look for you the Home Secretary will
have a legal duty to remove anyone
entering the UK illegally
the bill allows the Detention of illegal
arrivals without bail or judicial review
for the first 28 days of detention or
until they can be removed as of 2021 the
UK had just over 2 500 detention places
on current levels of migration that
means the UK would be able to
accommodate less than 20 percent of the
capacity
well migrants won't be able to use
modern slavery laws to stop their
removal and challenges will only be
heard after they have left the UK
the Home Secretary said she wouldn't
address the full legal complexities of
the bill and the government says it
isn't sure the bill is compatible with
the European convention on human rights
an annual cap on the number of refugees
being accepted by the UK will be decided
by MPS in Westminster and migrants
arriving by illegal routes risk a
permanent ban on settlement citizenship
and re-entry to the UK
well despite some concerns the Prime
Minister Rishi sulak has insisted the
legislation will stand up to any legal
tests it encounters
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
either to their own country if it is
safe to do so or to a safe Third Country
like Rwanda
and once you are removed you will be
banned as you are in America and
Australia from ever re-entering our
country five years ago the then Home
Secretary Javid said he was going to
make this route on viable since then we
know we've seen tens of thousands of
people in the last five years where do
you think your predecessors went wrong
why are you different and can I also ask
what does success look like to you will
you be setting targets for where you
want the numbers to be in a year's time
so this is not about dwelling on the
past because the situation has just got
far worse as I said in my remarks
earlier just in the last two years you
talked about when Sergeant was Home
Secretary so just in the last two years
the numbers of people crossing the
channel legally have more than
quadrupled right that is the scale of
what is happening and they're forecast
to get worse successes are stopping the
boats success is us having a system that
people come here illegally are returned
back to their own country where it's
safe or an alternative we don't believe
it is necessary to leave the CHR we
believe that we're acting in compliance
with it and acting meeting our
International obligations but as I said
also meeting our obligations to the
British public to have control over our
borders and ensure that it's them and
they elected government who's into in
control of who is coming here
okay well let's discuss the
practicalities and legalities of those
plans joining me in the studio is the
immigration solicitor her job Singh
bungle we also have Kay Marsh from the
Dover migrants rights charity the sam5
project and we're set to be joined
hopefully by the conservative MP Danny
Krueger here in the studio I believe he
is on his way um well let's first of all
talk about the legalities at her job
with yourself
um the prime minister is convinced this
is compliant with international law
Zoella bravaman not so convinced in a
letter she sent to MPS which I plan to
put to Danny Krueger I mean it she says
we're pushing the boundaries on
international law is that you're either
pushing the boundaries you're in within
the law or you're breaking it aren't you
yeah I mean law is quite simple like
that you either complying with it or
you're breaking with it pushing the
boundaries the phrase seems like a
caveat just in case sort of letting you
know that you know what we're going to
have a go but if it doesn't work out
then I'm going to have a fullback and
I'll say I did try and I did have a go
but it hasn't worked out and I did warn
you before beforehand and the blame no
less well someone will be blamed usually
judges lawyers and migrants themselves
and European courts I want to get down
into the detail as we say that it seems
like this might go through a lot of
legal contests shall we say in through
the courts like the Rwanda policy did
there does seem to be a gap between the
law of the land obviously if you don't
come enter the country with a Visa then
you are considered illegal an
international law the refugee Convention
of course states that you have a right
to enter if you are claiming Asylum as a
refugee
so where's the Gap because the
government repeatedly used this term as
I've mentioned in in our headlines there
anyone arriving illegally are refugees
illegal
um so to claim Asylum is not illegal the
government have made if you enter the
country without a Visa then it's illegal
but it hasn't told us how to legally
then claim Asylum because there's no
safe way to claim Asylum unless you're
from Ukraine or Afghanistan or fit into
a specific scheme which we've seen as
very limited and very few visas are
granted under that they're not well run
you might remember the Ukraine scheme
where people were running away from
Ukraine ending up in Paris and Calais
and trying to claim for Asylum and then
told actually you know you've got to go
back to Ukraine to a claim Asylum so
they're very shoddy at best we don't
have the infrastructure for this but we
need to consider a scheme or an option
and that's been alluded to today where
people can claim Asylum and and not risk
the journey across and they have an
alternative if you're not going to give
people an alternative and you take away
the only method
then I don't think that's really fair
and I don't think that's really going to
work that's okay we don't want anyone
here to K Marsh then
um Kate Marsha will it work is this
going to act as the deterrent that the
government says it it wants it to be
well I think first of all um we've seen
in the last decade that the parents
simply don't work do they this is this
is the only strategy we've had now for
quite some time and the numbers have
continued to go up
um I think you hit the nail on the head
there we need a safe alternative at the
moment the safe legal routes that are
available are very narrow criteria and
the average person couldn't hope to be
helped through them which which forces
innocent people with legitimate claims
to Asylum into a regular Crossing small
boats and the like and you know risk
their lives and what choice do they have
this is the point
umak said that the only route into the
UK would be a safe and legal one but of
course at the moment I we do not have
adequate safe and legal routes it's a
no-brainer it really is okay but it is
fair to say though the government's
point of people risking their lives to
make this journey and not just risking
their lives lives have been lost young
and and old this is a dangerous journey
and it's the criminal gangs that are
benefiting from all of this charging
people exorbitant amounts of money as
well as as their lives being lost on the
way is this a way of at least protecting
migrants and Asylum Seekers lives
I don't think there's any protection
built into this new bill at all it's
it's completely
inhumane you know we'll see people the
majority of people coming over innocent
traumatized people being detained and
re-traumatized how is that fair or
Humane in any way no absolutely not
okay her job I want to talk to you about
um how they're to be more legal
challenges yeah and what could they be
potentially definitely legal challenges
but practical problems so we heard Rishi
sunak say today that we're going to send
people back to their country of origin
or other safe countries or Rwanda first
of all Rwanda only has 200 places we
initially agreed 500 places they came
back a week later and said no mate we
only have 200 places right so that's the
first thing that we need to consider
we're not going to get 10 000 people in
Rwanda and I think that's what maybe the
British public might have been promised
here today or been sold a dream into
doing the other and what about the legal
challenges do you think there are
potentially yeah the legal immigration
the legal challenges you can't prevent
people from claiming Asylum so it's very
contradictory in in one sense you're
saying we're going to send people back
straight away not let them claim Asylum
but then why are you going to hold them
in a detention center for 28 days for
and why are you gonna why you saying
we're going to Fast Track the process so
that means you are considering their
claim for Asylum and you're going to
Fast Track them so we need to be clear
on that the other thing is to send
people back afterwards you need to have
return agreements we've only got six so
I want to come to you that today in a
minute actually yeah well one of the
main criticisms of the government is uh
that not enough is being done to crack
down on the people Smugglers providing
the small boats and sending them across
the channel while this weekend our
Europe correspondent Adam Parsons spoke
to one of those providing the boats and
sending people on the dangerous return
journey in return for money
foreign
would it make a difference if people
were sent to Rwanda when they arrived
British government has threatened to do
this would that change the business
model well
foreign
was brought up today in the House of
Commons by the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper who attacked the
government over its inability to bring
Smugglers to account
the deputy chair of the conservative
party said yesterday we shouldn't go
after the gangs because while they've
existed for thousands of years that is
the disgraceful Tory attitude that's met
The Gangs of the hook and letting the
gangs take hold on one Smuggler told Sky
News yesterday that three-quarters of
the Smugglers live in Britain yet barely
any of them are being prosecuted and
they still haven't found the hundreds of
children missing from Asylum hotels
who've been picked up by criminal gangs
they could be setting out a serious plan
today and we would work through them on
it and so would everyone across the
country instead it's just more chaos
well still with me in the studio for
this Sky News special is the immigration
solicitor her job Singh bungle we also
have Kay Marsh from the Dover migrants
rights charity the Sam fire project and
K the trouble is isn't it that we're
talking about the this new policy acting
as a deterrent but it's not a rational
decision to get on these boats is it
it's one that is driven by desperation
and people Smugglers as we've seen just
there will carry on making the money and
getting people on boats as long as
people are desperate
yes absolutely as you say um it's not a
rational decision
um and people don't make these decisions
lightly they make them because they have
no other choice so yes they will keep
putting money into the pocket for people
Smugglers because it is pretty much
their only option you know and I think
it's a really interesting point from
Yvette Cooper there uh the government
are very quick to to bring up people's
Smugglers all the time you know breaking
the business model of the people
Smugglers why are they not going after
convictions for the the people Smugglers
living in the UK you know and maybe
that's where their focus should be but
no you're absolutely right this these
are desperate people
yeah and and tell me how how what people
tell you about the willingness to risk
their lives to take these trips across
the channel
they don't see any other option you know
they they feel like they're they're
forced into this this situation and that
they don't have any other options that's
literally what we hear you know and I
mean it makes sense doesn't it I mean
what would it take for you to get into a
small boat in the middle of winter in a
shorts and t-shirt you know with your
child
you can see can't you it is the act of a
desperate person and not somebody trying
to to get themselves 40 pounds a week
okay okay um well let's turn to you her
job um tell us about uh the Crackdown on
people smugglers in the country and and
whether that is is going far enough in
your opinion as far as the law is
concerned or or do there need to be
changes in the law as far as that is
concerned well I think it's we need to
get the idea first that there's more
money made in people smuggling than
there is in drug smuggling yet we hear
and a lot of people don't know that yet
we hear about a war on drugs and we hear
about people special secret services and
special agencies going to catch drug
Warlords drug Barons you never hear of
people Smugglers getting caught and it's
not hard to find them because we know
and everyone else seems to know that
they've been operating for the last 20
years while I've been looking at it from
the same Coast Calais and have been
sending people to the same Coast the
Kent Coast for 20 years now if we can go
and get Osama Bin Laden hold up in
Pakistan somewhere and we can go and get
Saddam Hussein in his stronghold and put
him on trial are we really trying to
tell the British public that we don't
know where these gangs are and we can't
get them that's almost akin to saying
that there's a bus driver who drives the
same bus for the past 20 years with the
same passengers from A to B and when the
governments we ask the government okay
you need to get the bus driver don't
know where he is sorry he's 20 seconds
where's the problem is it the policing
is it the law Can the police catch them
but they they don't have enough evidence
or are there not enough laws that in
place to to tackle equipment the
government will never tell us and it
seems today as if Richie sunak has
almost said you know what we can't catch
the gangs so we're going to punish the
users and we're going to hope that by
punishing the users the gangs are going
to go away the gangs do not care they're
in this business for money to make money
they don't care what laws are passed in
the UK or what doesn't they're going to
put people on a boat regardless and
Asylum Seekers don't get up in the
morning and say let's find a diggy and
let's come over this is organized crime
they pay for a service to come over here
you've it's like I said it's almost akin
to set to hoping that let's lock up all
the drug users and hope that drug
dealing stops it's never going to work
okay we've got about a minute left I do
want to put this to you because time and
again we hear the fact
people are clearly very wealthy they're
paying these drug smugglers a lot of
money is that relevant relevance in your
view
no I don't think it is relevant it's
about as relevant as the argument of why
do they turn up with mobile phones you
know these are people from civilized
well civilized countries you know
they're normal people They have normal
lives until you know disaster hits in
one way or another and when that happens
you liquidate your assets and you get
you get out and you get your family out
you know this is what you do and so it's
not abnormal but normal people would
have houses to sell or cars or mobile
phones it's just they're just normal
people I don't know why people expect
them to be poverty-stricken you know it
could happen to anybody
okay K and hardship you're staying with
us this is a Sky News special program on
the crisis in the channel coming up
could the French authorities do more to
help crack down on people's Smugglers
and small bows we'll look ahead to Rishi
sunax meeting with the French President
Emmanuel macron
[Music]
this fluid in as you mentioned is an
anesthetic gas we have three anesthetic
gases and an interview agent
um there was a a an acknowledgment um a
few years back that this gas was much
worse than uh most other gases and for
the environment and in fact we
discovered as you as you mentioned it's
two and a half thousand times the amount
of carbon dioxide and the effect and so
if you use this fluorine for instance if
I use days fluorine for one day
um I would probably have the equivalent
mileage of driving over a thousand
kilometers whereas if you used an
alternative drug a drug called Silver
fluorine it would be about 16 kilometers
so you can understand the the desire to
try to reduce its use we started
reducing the use in 2017 and in fact in
my own Hospital stopped using the drug
in 2019 but up until this year we still
had some small numbers across the UK
still using it um the the decision this
year this last month in Scotland was to
stop the contract for buying it which
will really encourage uh you know the
the decrease use but um in fact NHS
England also have a plan to do the same
thing stop the contract by next spring
so we should have significant reduction
in the carbon output
um for instance the the the the the
difference in Scotland will be about 6.2
kilotons of carbon dioxide saved
um and of course that will be reflected
across the other nations so there are a
number of things we can do obviously
there are specific drugs and gases that
we use that we can reduce the use of or
or mitigate in some way
um but there's simple things like
reducing energy use uh looking at
Pharmaceuticals getting into the water
um even just looking at the single
Plastics culture that we've developed
within Healthcare and seeing if we can
reverse that Trend in a safe way
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to this special program on
the crisis in the channel we're taking a
look at the government's new legislation
on illegal migration and asking if the
government can deliver on its promise to
stop the small boats well I'm joined by
the conservative MP Danny Krueger good
to have you in the studio finally the
immigration solicitor her job Singh
punggol and we also have K Marsh from
the Dover migrants rights charity the
Sam fire project or more from them in a
moment but first we've spoken a lot
about what the British government wants
to do but many feel it can only be
achieved with the cooperation of the
French authorities well later this week
Richie sunac will meet with French
president Emmanuel macron together can
they do anything to stop people leaving
French Shores well let's speak to our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins who
is in Dunkirk this evening and has been
hearing from those who thinking about
make taking the journey and Siobhan what
have people there been telling you
hi good evening yes I've been visiting
the camps here in Dunkirk and also down
in Calais today to talk to people who
are there many of them waiting to make
these Journeys in the small boats across
the channel to find out whether this
bill will make any difference and the
short answer is at the moment no no one
I spoke to knew anything about it when I
explained the detail to them they also
didn't think that it would make that
much difference and you can hear now
from a man called izay he's planning to
make the journey to the UK because his
wife is there She's suffering from
cancer and she She's suffering from
cancer and he doesn't believe that if he
waited for a Visa that he would have
time to get there so for him he believes
that he has to get there as soon as
possible so that's why he's going to
risk taking a boat I spoke to other
people as well who were telling me well
this isn't the beginning of my journey
I've escaped from Afghanistan I've made
this route for example people through
turkey many of them have talked about
being beaten and exploited along the
Route they've got here and then when you
say to them you can't do that final leg
well they're just not going to give up
they've already paid their money to
Smugglers and also today even when this
bill was being discussed in the UK we
could overhear conversations within the
camps with middlemen who were talking
about the weather and clearly working
out whether there were going to be any
other Crossings this week because to be
honest it's not politics which is
dictating what's happening in those
camps at the moment it's the weather is
the wind tying off is it too high can
they get across uh quickly and so it's a
really massive challenge as you say it's
one that the UK wants to try and solve
in cooperation with France and Europe
and it has been working closer with
France but I think we'll find out more
on Friday in this UK French Summit about
what steps will go in the future and
also how the French receive this update
Siobhan thanks very much indeed live
from Dunkirk for us tonight well let's
discuss this further with uh
conservative MP Danny Krueger plus the
immigration solicitor her job Singh
bungle and Kate Marsh from the Dover
migrants rights charity the Sam fire
project Danny Krueger first to you um
good to have you with us in the studio
uh first let's address what Siobhan uh
Robbins was just saying there she's
speaking to people they are not deterred
they are desperate and Kmart says people
are are driven by desperation this
policy isn't going to work because
people are still going to take the risks
well isn't it a tragedy that so many
people have been as it were enticed to
the French Coast by the prospect of
claiming as item in the UK if they can
only make that last hop across the
channel and they're prepared to risk
their lives and spend a lot of money to
do so we need to make sure that
everybody understands that that work
work and there's enormous demand around
the world tragically you know 100
million people on the move because of
War drought all sorts of of conflict and
we need to send a strong signal that you
can't break into the UK we have a
generous Asylum policy I think there's
major improvements that we can make to
that which we could discuss
the fundamental fact is you should not
be allowed to claim Asylum if you break
into this country illegally and that's
the signal that everybody needs to to
hear the interesting use of words some
of those have been picked up today in by
analysts saying there's a lot of
scaremongering going on the use of the
figure 100 million and and you've just
used the terminology breaking into the
country as I understand it from
discussions throughout the day here on
Sky News multiple lawyers have told us
that it's not illegal to come to the UK
to seek Asylum well no one is illegal in
the act of claiming Asylum but the means
of Entry to the UK are illegal and
that's what we need to deter we
absolutely need a proper Asylum policy
we need to be ensuring that people can
claim aside are much closer to the
region that they are displaced from we
need a proper Global route a safe Global
route to enable people to come here
remember we have a lot of those routes
currently 450 000 people have come to
the UK in the last seven years through
the safe and legal routes but only a
limited number of countries well
so the largest numbers have come from a
small number of countries there are a
couple of global routes that are
available the problem is they're not
working very well and there's a number
of important reasons for that but we
have through the unhcr a global route
what we need to do is to make that work
I'd be interested in thoughts on how to
but the fundamental thing is you've got
to go through a legal route to claim
Asylum otherwise there's no point in
trying to have any kind of system that
will work as long as there is the
opportunity to come here through illegal
means we will have the crisis in the
channel and that's what we've got to
stop okay her job do you have um
response to that well we welcome the you
know beginning of safe fruits so there
needs to be a safe route what can't
happen is that you take away the only
route available and then offer nothing
in return so safe routes will act as a
deterrent of some sort and will
definitely hit the model of the gangs
but it's not the B1 angle there's a lot
of changes that need to happen faster
processing why is it taking two years to
process a claim which off after you've
got the evidence should take a skilled
person about half a day so why why is
that happening why is the home office
still not fit for purpose after John
Reed told us how many years ago that
it's not fit for purpose why hasn't
there been investment why is it the
staff not fully trained why on top of
that are the gangs not sought after why
are we just saying okay we're going to
give up on the gangs and why have we not
got why did we enter into an agreement
without any return agreements there's a
lot of frustrations
the Prime Minister said today that it's
costing the taxpayer a lot of money he
is right it is costing the taxpayer a
lot of money but it's it's not the
refugees on small boats fault is it it's
a failed system presided over by your
government well I mean there's a lot to
be well there's a there's a lot to fix
and a lot of those problems I absolutely
recognize as well and there are major
difficulties with the speed of
processing a lot of that is because of
the rights legislation we have the
modern slavery act things that frankly
enable claimants to protract their claim
and to make it much more difficult to do
the processing but absolutely also we
need to stop the gangs uh there's a lot
of action being taking place on that
front a lot of cooperation with the
French has improved major investment in
border security hundreds more staff
patrolling the French Coast with Bridget
from faithful by the British many more
uh processing officers here in the UK so
there's all of that things need all that
stuff needs to be done absolutely and we
need to improve removals which we can
come on to but the fundamental factors
as long as there is the opportunity to
break into this country illegally and I
that is the description of what happens
then people will continue to do so
because we will never be able no matter
how good our safe route is to cater to
the potential demand in the world so the
small boats route is is not actually the
only route that is to blame right right
now it feels like there's a lot of
political rhetoric putting all eyes on
the small boats and trying to create a
distraction perhaps in the run up to an
election
well that's where the bulk of the
illegal Crossings are taking place now
it used to be said it's the only
Crossing possible well because we've
successfully stopped the route that was
we were all worried about a few years
ago which was on the lorries and on the
on the train so no we now have a system
that prevents illegal migration on a
great scale I mean there are other other
routes but the big one we need to worry
about is these small boats to stop that
you need to break their business model
that's about enforcement but mostly it's
about sending a strong signal around the
world that you will not be able to claim
asylum in the UK if you come across the
channel illegally
would you like to see from
Emmanuel macron so there's two things
one is increased uh well an improved
border security Corporation across the
channel and we do work much better I
think than we used to with the fridge
they weren't patrolling their beaches as
well as we wanted them to them now I
think I understand there's significant
Improvement there but no doubt we can do
more and the other thing we need to
ensure is a proper returns policy so we
need to ensure that people who come here
from the EU if next week's they can be
returned directly to the their home
country if that's not a European country
and for many it is remember we have a 10
000 albanians coming uh over the last
year so if they can't be returned to a
European country then they need to be
returned to uh to their home country or
to a safe Third Country all that
requires the cooperation of the EU and
the French in particular okay are you
confident this is legal and this won't
be kicked out well actually not yet
because we really need to be sure that
the we probably need to interrogate the
details of the law to ensure that I'm
afraid to say the very activist and very
clever legal industry in our country
who's very good at picking holes in in
the legislation and challenging
individual cases won't succeeds so we
need to ensure that this this is
watertight I think there is genuine
problems with the European convention on
human rights which is what stopped the
last which you see next says there's no
need well indeed not you want to leave
no no I think we should be prepared to
do so I don't think there should be any
International obligations that stop us
in forcing sovereignty over our borders
I believe him when he says that this law
will enable us to overcome echr barriers
and we should do what's necessary to
make sure that's the case so you think
we should be prepared to leave the echr
uh need to give a final word of course
to Kay Marshall who works with these
people on a regular basis and speaks to
people okay okay Marsh what what do you
make of what Danny Krueger had to say
well the choice of language was very
interesting there
um enticed and things like this it makes
it sound like it's a pleasurable option
for people
um which of course it isn't you know and
I think we need to reiterate the fact
that there aren't adequate safe routes
at the moment and we do need to look at
that as a priority
um people don't want to make these
Crossings people want to get here safely
um regarding whether or not this will go
through
um I don't hold that much hope at all I
don't see any way that it could be in
accordance with international law I
certainly hope that it's not okay Kate
Marsh from the Dover migrants rights
charity Sapphire project her job seeing
Bengal immigration lawyer and Danny
Krueger conservative MP thanks very much
indeed for joining us for this Sky News
special on the small boat it's good to
have you with us in the studio